[Music]
in case you've been hiding under a rock
or if you just don't have Twitter bless
your heart Kanye West made his return to
the platform and proceeded to crack the
internet with seven dirty words which
would have put even George Carlin to
shame last Saturday Kanye tweeted I love
the way Candace Owens thinks if you
don't know Candace Owens she's a black
conservative woman who originally went
under the YouTube moniker red pill black
Candace caught fire online around the
summer of 2017 and my interview with her
in which we discussed her evolution from
a lefty to a conservative is one of the
moments that really put her on the map
it was the first time that she had been
able to explain herself in her own words
in a long-form conversational setting I
don't want to rehash the whole thing
right now but Candace is no stranger to
controversy and you may remember that
infamous debate that I had with Candace
and Blair white late last year the whole
thing was a debacle I make no bones
about it but hashtag save Dave trended
on Twitter so Who am I to complain 2018
has already been a huge year for Candace
as she was hired as communications
director for Turning Point USA the
largest conservative college group in
America since then she's been touring
the country with Charlie Kirk talking to
young people particularly young black
people as why they should embrace the
victor mentality rather than the victim
mentality this is included directly
attacking the black lives matter
movement as well as democratic policies
which Candice argues has decimated the
black family and the black community
just last week Candice Charlie and I
spoke at Berkeley to a wild crowd I'm
proud to say that we had agreements and
we had disagreements and even though our
styles are different no doubt Candis
certainly goes for the jugular more than
I do I always enjoyed doing events with
her and seeing her evolve politically
something I know a bit about myself
she's learning as she goes and as she
said to me in our interview if I had
swallowed the red pill then she had
snorted it beyond any of the politics
though Candice is a friend and our
differences don't define us they
actually bring us together all right
back to Kanye for a second beyond the
headlines I don't know what ton about
him although I'm obviously aware enough
to recognize what a transcendent
cultural figure he is
not only is he hugely successful in the
music world he has a hugely successful
fashion line and is married to Kim
Kardashian who has her own Empire you
may not like the guy for whatever reason
but make no mistake he is an absolute
mogul I may not like or even respect the
influence that celebrities have over
culture these days but Kanye is truly
someone who can move people's minds with
what he raps or with what he tweets this
is exactly what happened with these
seven words immediately after Kanye's
tweet in support of Candace the internet
went ablaze Twitter moments lead story
was about Kanye support for far-right
Candace Owens Candice was called anti
gay and racist something I'm still
confused about as she's had dinner here
with me and my husband at our home where
her anti gayness never seemed to leak
out as for Asus there's nothing like a
white lefty telling a black person who
doesn't think as they demand that they
do that the black person is the actual
racist against their own race irony is
truly dead folks on Monday this week
Kanye refused to back down despite
hysterics from the media he tweeted out
a bunch of videos by another former
Rubin report guest best-selling author
and Dilbert creator Scott Adams in
essence these videos were Scott talking
about what a freethinker Kanye is that's
it next thing you know the usual
suspects like BuzzFeed mediate The Daily
Beast and others were labeling Scott
Adams as far-right we've seen the script
a million times before with anyone who
dare challenge leftist orthodoxy be it
Candice Scott Colin Moriarty Jordan
Peterson or even little ol me when
mainstream media has moved so far left
that this wide collection of people are
all smeared with the same charges of
far-right racism you know that the
Overton Window hasn't just shifted it's
shattered the authors of these pieces
aren't journalists they're activists or
as Candace says they aren't journalists
their hit men to recap we have a new
player in Candace who is fearlessly
saying how she believes that the
Democrats have used the black community
for decades and that the victimhood
mentality of the left is the root of
this problem this by the way is similar
to what plenty of other conservatives
have been saying for years and yes this
includes even black
conservatives like my former guests
Larry elder and Thomas soul the voices
of black conservatives and others
espousing similar ideas has been largely
ignored by the mainstream media however
and that is exactly why everyone is
freaking out about Kanye's tweets he
just gave oxygen to a set of ideas that
the Democrats and the mainstream media
don't want you to hear and since they've
controlled the narrative for so long
they've relied on the usual smears of
racism homophobia and bigotry instead of
strengthening their own ideas your ideas
get fat and lazy when you don't have to
work them out because you've owned the
narrative for so long this is where the
modern left finds itself right now if
Candace's views are far-right then that
means that about 40% of America if not
more falls into that category I do want
to address a different lurking danger
here however I know Candis and I believe
her to be forthright and passionate as
she figures this all out I obviously
don't know Kanye nor any of his
political beliefs so we have an
interesting match here where Candis is
now the rocket and Kanye is the jet fuel
if Candis doesn't do the intellectual
work to really figure out what she
believes and why she believes it all the
while being under the insane microscope
of the media that's gonna be praying for
her to fail well then the rocket will be
faulty and this experiment will blow up
what if Kanye says something absolutely
crazy tomorrow which is not only
possible it's probable or something
that's counter to everything else that
Candice believes he's been known to stir
the pot and I can only assume that
something like that will happen either
intentionally or by mistake
does her rocket ship run out of fuel in
mid-flight where does that leave this
incredible momentum over the past year
when I've talked to people like Eric and
brett weinstein jordan peterson ben
shapiro larry elder Thomas Saul and many
others what I'm most impressed by is how
complete their outlook on politics and
more broadly on life is they don't jump
from conclusion to conclusion depending
on the political climate they try to
really understand what they
fundamentally think so as new issues
arise their responses are complete
rather than conflicted this is something
I've really tried to incorporate into my
thinking and something that I know many
of you are trying to do as well
this
we'll also be Candace's challenge now
and I think she's up to it but only she
can decide that for herself it blows my
mind that every conversation we have in
this room seems to become more and more
relevant as time goes by for all I know
we'll have Kanye in that guest seat soon
enough whether he is just rocket fuel to
boost ideas or is he the rocket ship
that will get us to the solutions
remains to be seen but make no mistake
the issues around free speech political
correctness and the uncomfortable truths
that might be the answers to those
questions have just been levelled up are
the players ready for the next level
we'll soon find out
[Music]
joining me today is a national security
expert the best-selling author of
defeating jihad and a former albeit
brief strategist to president Trump dr.
Sebastian Gorka welcome to the Rubin
report thanks Lambie David I'm happy to
have you here sir first off that voice
you have a very have you ever done any
voice-over work at all
it's don't tell anybody but it's my
dream when I wrote defeating jihad and I
asked about the audio book I said I'm
gonna get to do the audio book write to
my publisher you can do the prologue
then we'll get a pro I was crushed all
right so the next book coming out in
June why we fight I'm sorry if you're
listening Margie I'm doing voiceover so
I really can't believe that so first up
we have already spent a good amount of
time talking about Star Wars so I am
very impressed your green room and that
post I'd never seen that in the quarry
poster before yeah I'm the LP so I'm
impressed that is the original 1977
poster I wonder do you think because
we're obviously gonna talk a lot about
national security and foreign policy and
all that do you think any of your
thoughts related to foreign policy have
anything to do with Star Wars because I
do think at some level some of the way I
view the world has been shaped by some
of the lore and yeah I'm not sure if
it's cause and effect but but absolutely
in terms of good and evil I mean totally
I mean the first three movies are about
good versus evil before they become this
social justice warrior absurdity so yes
I mean but as much as being the son of
people who lived under Nazi and then
communist dictatorship these things kind
of flowed together so Star Wars and
growing up under the child of people
escaped from dictation right there yeah
all right so you are in California
because you were talking to a couple
conservative groups here in California
people don't believe that conservative
groups could exist in California but I
mentioned to you before we just had
Governor John Kasich on he was talking
with Arnold Schwarzenegger at some
conservative groups here in California
so there it seems like something is
happening in California I don't live
here but I come in and out to do these
events as something's happening so
something clearly is happening the
energy I felt at the the events here is
it's like the energy I feel at events in
Virginia or elsewhere like Texas and
there's a commonality whoever you speak
to they keep mentioning the same things
they talk about the gas tax they talk
about sanctuary cities they talk about
the burden on businesses when you get
these things repeated enough times you
realize something is happening in
California who knows where it'll go but
this this isn't the state I used to say
you know the People's Republic just lost
forever I'm not so sure anymore
really so do you think this could be
something that could happen as soon as
our next our gubernatorial election
that's coming up now or do you think
this is sort of long term maybe
presidential election 2020 year all I'll
say is the following with the election
of Donald J Trump to president the
political rulebook has been shredded
burnt buried and the Donald Trump jumped
up and down on it it's gone so so any
past expectations any trend lines are
irrelevant I mean I traveled with the
President to we flew on Air Force One to
Youngstown Ohio back in June and this is
steel Valley right this is the heart of
a blue-collar Democrat manual laborers
and we we arrived at the stadium
and the president was in the back I was
you know doing selfies with you know the
crowd who do love the crowd selfie I've
seen many polls what does it cost me you
know they want a selfie yes sure why not
yeah so I got to engage with these
people and I realized that in this
stadium around twenty twenty-five
thousand people everybody was either a
former registered Democrat their parents
their grandparents or all Democrats and
then what happens when the president
went when the First Lady Melania comes
out of the stage it erupts the building
erupts with chants of the USA drain the
swamp and this is democrat territory now
if that can happen in youngstown our
Youngstown Ohio who knows what can
happen in California yeah so I want to
talk a little bit about your history and
your parents and growing up that I'm
just mentioned but as long as we're on
the on the first part of the Trump
portion of this let's just keep doing
that I heard you at the turning point
USA event in December give a speech
which I really thought was wonderful and
you described Trump as the ice breaker
and what I've been saying around here is
that I view him as the bull in the china
shop we wanted a panther to knock over a
few things but we got the bull and I
think that really it's really the same
analogy that we're using there so can
you just yeah I don't further on that a
little bit so the United States was
covered for at least 30 years in this
massive permafrost layer of ice which is
political correctness and it had frozen
over the media education politics all of
it to the extent that by the Obama
administration
federal government was telling you who
could use which bathroom right so just
insanity and then along comes a guy who
the first day I met him in summer of
June 15 in his office in Trump Tower the
first thing I knew about this man is
he's the Kryptonite of political
correctness I mean he couldn't care less
about what the New York Times or CNN
says about a given issue so along comes
this man layer of ice frozen over the
country BAM slams into it like an ice
breaker and smashes through the ice so
he breaks a pathway for for the nation
to to open up that sea lane and my
argument to conservative audiences is
that this is great this is monumental it
wasn't going to be the patter patter
never have one it had to be the ball it
had to be the icebreaker but if you know
your physics of ice breaking you can
send that you know thousands of tons
worth of ship in there with its tungsten
how rides up on the ice slices through
it but if you don't have the flotilla
behind it that comes up and keeps that
passageway open what actually happens in
real life is you send one ship in breaks
a path almost instantaneously the ice
comes around the bow andreen its itself
right around the ship and reseals so
this is the moment in the conservative
movement well we have to get serious of
about what does it mean to be a
conservative in the 21st century what's
the role of government how does a
national security look so on and so
forth
Donald Trump is the catalyst now we have
to do the heavy lifting of ideology and
politics and policy yeah do you think he
will years from now when we look back be
anything other than the catalyst like
how do you how do you consider his ideas
compared to traditionally conservative
ideas because just in the last couple
months after signing the omnibus thing
you know right now when we're take we're
taping this a few days before we're
gonna air it but there there's a big
mess in Syria we're not sure you know if
there's gonna be more intervention or
not he seems to be doing some things
that are probably a little more big
government than perhaps you want
horst certainly than his base seems to
want so where do you think he fits
actually between catalyst and and the
flotilla so first things first
I hate Able's personally IIIi think
labels is lazy thinking and in the case
of Donald Trump very relevant and then
they have no application our credit
Monica Monica Crowley my friend with
this the weekend after the election was
David horowitz's was it a restoration
weekend yeah in Florida yeah which was
either going to be awake or the party
that was and Monica gave a great speech
in which he said look everybody
misunderstands who this man is he was
never an ideological candidate because
you simply cannot put him in a box
because of what he does whether it's his
attitude to gay marriage whether it's it
just he's what it's just a mixture he
was never an ideological candidate he
was an attitudinal candidate and she
nailed it now what does that mean look
at the last 40 years this guy's 71 years
old he's not going to change he is
is what has he done for the last 40
years as a professional he's been
committed to one thing excellence
whether it's a golf course in shopton
whether it's a skyscraper in New York
its excellence and all he's done is he's
taken that concept and tried you know
translated it into excellence for
America once more and that doesn't fit
into neat neoliberal neocon paleo calm
it just doesn't fit
he's about getting stuff done and being
the best but so how do you link that to
what the general conservative movement
is now I get what you're saying about
labels and I say it all the time the
labels now especially because of Trump
the labels are all the brothers at this
point but the thing that I'm struggling
to fully grasp about the Trump thing is
how does this connect to you know when I
see it you right now you have a huge
split right we've got the the Trump base
and then you've got the never Trump errs
and these people are that should be kind
of lining up they can't quite get there
and how do you connect those things like
how do you connect what yeah but the
never Trump is a pathological I mean
pathological when when Bill Kristol you
know who's all obsequious and all he a
genus to me in the green room at Fox
when he tweets out actually tweets out
in a choice between the deep state and
president Trump I choose the deep state
yeah bill you're not a conservative
you're a subversive right okay get out
of the tent get out of the tent so
that's never going to happen
the broader question of what is
conservative me today we can't answer
that because have you seen a good
article a really good article which
understands first principles founding
principles about what Trump ism is or
should be I haven't I've seen a lot of
people who think they know what they're
talking about but who've never met the
president so I think with a lot of work
to be done but it's not going to be done
by conservative establishment
individuals if the NRA is not going to
tell you who Trump is right and the
Inara is not going to revitalize the
conservative establishment right this is
a new year it's exciting but we have to
get to work to define what it means
so that to me is why it seems so obvious
that you're so passionate about this
that nobody else was going to do it and
I think that's also that's sort of what
Monica was saying and it's sort of what
Horowitz has been saying for a long time
even when he sat right there
that no one else was gonna break through
and now it's imperfect but at least
there's me you know be brutally candid
you know I grew up in the UK to
Hungarian parents of escape communism I
went through the the private school
system in the UK stiff upper lip and all
that stuff for the debating Club so the
president's style is not exactly the
style I'm used to right I get to get
used to it and I understand what people
of issues the biggest people biggest
thing people have issues with on the
right are his tweets I get it
but guess what who was going to defeat
Hillary wasn't Jeb Bush yeah wasn't even
say at a cruise none of them were going
to the only person who could cut through
that miasma who could break through the
ice of political correctness was this
rank outsider from Manhattan and whether
you like it or not he to say for Asafa
Kalihi was the necessary but not
sufficient cause of victory you don't
have to like it but it had to be him
with that stuff we tried to do Marquess
of Queensbury rules for thirty years
where did it get us where did it get us
Mitt Romney
grandma guys right right so it had to be
Donald Trump now we have to backfill
what it means yeah and that seems to be
where I think you and so many of these
other people that are either part or
formerly part of the administration so
you had a very brief stint at the
administration first of all even some
look right years from now they'll go my
god he was there for 90 percent longer
than everybody else but a pretty brief
stint 7 months first can you tell me how
you got involved because you had only
you just mentioned you only met him a
little bit before the election in the
first place and then and then sort of
what happened that had you leave because
that rule really tie into the media
which I think we're very much aligned on
what's going on with the media right now
so a summer of 15 I get a phone call
from a guy called Corey Lewandowski that
I'd never heard
and he said candidate Trump is prepping
for the big full GOP presidential debate
on national security he'd like to talk
to you said sure so I took the plane
flew to New York went to Trump Tower it
was just the three of us in Donald
Trump's office and we had this
incredible blue sky discussion on
national security issues you name it
from the Civil War after the Middle East
to nuclear weapons all kinds of topics
how knowledgeable did he seem about
things because this is one of the parts
that I think people we have no handle on
like this you really haven't really
interested yeah but not a guy that
you're gonna debate what happened in
Karbala in the ninth century but but but
really interested in this stuff and with
opinions and and halfway through this
discussion and he was sitting closer to
me than you are and Cory's over here
and he does a classic trumpism he goes
just stops the conversation Cory I like
this guy let's hire him and that was it
and he asked me to help right it wasn't
part of the campaign but I became an
adviser policy papers that he used in
the briefings and and we stayed in touch
but I never joined the campaign and then
as things progressed and he you know the
field whittled down to what it did I
kept meeting general Flynn at events I
was a participant just in the crowd I
kept bumping into general Flynn and I'd
known him from when he was directed to
dia and eventually we just he pulled me
in and by October the month before the
election I know if you're familiar with
the system and in in the presidential
election the last two runners get
support from the federal government
before the election and they get offices
near the White House to create
transition teams to prep and so Hillary
got one story and and the president got
another story this building and I was
pulled into the pen hilarious it's in
the same building oh yeah and you cut if
you talk in the elevator right so so I
got pulled in and asked to work on the
National Security Council transition
team for general Flynn and my wife who
has a background in the issues was
pulled in to work on the DHS to you and
so I became part of the official
transition team
and up till the very last moment the
week before you know maybe the week of
the inauguration I was going to be doing
counterterrorism stuff for general Flynn
in the NFC and then Steve Berman who
knows me yeah
reaches out to the last minutes of new
they're gonna come and work for me and
the office of the chief strategist as a
strategist to the president and that's
how you know at 12:01 on Johnny xx I
became a deputy assistant to the
president yeah so the second that
happened basically the media just went
bananas on you I mean every store I
mention to you that right now it no they
act when they went bananas was it even
before that no no it's very interesting
they didn't they didn't go bananas until
the the travel ban dropped and I
realized things were not going well in
terms of communicating the travel ban so
I said to Steve and I said to Sean guys
I've done a bit of media in the past I
can be the face of this stuff if you
want I mean we've got the NSC
communications team but I'm prepared to
go on CNN and debate these guys and so
they threw me into the the you know the
the fire and I loved it and the left
went nuts they're just absolutely worth
insane yeah and it was once I was very
representing the president on television
that out came the hit pieces and the
lights yeah so let's talk about that a
little bit because I see this happening
to almost everyone that I have any
degree of respect for I see it happen
I see it it's coming it's coming to me
now too I mean I see this to almost
anyone that I think is trying to be
somewhat honest yeah the endless attacks
I mean you know there were just a
endless slew of things that you're an
anti-semite and all of this craziness I
mean at the turning point event that I
saw you speak at you get one of the
strongest defenses of Israel that I've
ever heard but they almost take
everything and do the complete reverse
what do you make of that
tactic specifically where it's literally
the reverse of what the truth is it's
not just like we're gonna take a line
and make it seem a little different
we're a new sign that's absolutely you
know you've got a big viewership I I
know you're why I'm no long
progressive thing has got other yeah
having millions of views now and I'll
open up a little bit despite the size of
your audience um I have a reputation for
being a scary dude
and being a hard-ass that's fine but
after the seven months that I went
through and my family went through every
time every few weeks I have the same
emotional response and it probably
surprises your others as a human being I
want to try and understand how another
human being who's never met me who knows
nothing about me or what my family has
been through can write what they wrote
about me will say what they say about me
it leaves me speechless that you can
have such venomous hatred for somebody
and peddles so egregious sets of lives
and and you not only call yourself a
journalist but you actually think you're
a human being I was attacked and that's
fine because I'm a politically
commissioned officer of the president
I'm a proxy I was a proxy for Steve I
was a proxy for the present I understand
that that's okay but hey why don't we
debate the policies they never wanted to
never wanted to bake the policies was ad
hominem attacks and lives and secondly
it's okay to attack me but guess what
sort of can't attack my wife it's not
okay to attack my dead mother's
reputation and it's not a kid attack my
teenage high school-aged son either
these people are reprehensible and
they're out of control David and they're
not learning that doubling down so
that's the part that I'm concerned about
right now that it's people always ask me
I did an event in Irvine last night and
and the question I'm getting more and
more now is is this thing turning around
now I sense my sense is the
there is something brewing against it
there's something brewing finally and I
think any of us in this space are a
little piece of it but to me it's gonna
get a lot worse before it gets better
and that that's what I'm concerned about
you're nodding already so I suspect you
I think you're right under what
conditions does something like that
change if we rule out violence right we
don't want to have violence
okay we've you know the the worst war we
ever had was our Civil War
okay 600,000 Americans killed even
though they're subtly condoning violence
eeo of twitter's condoning it so let's
that's you know pray to the good Lord
that that's that's not where we're going
what's the other option
what's the other scenario that they look
in the mirror and they stopped but why
would they they reward each other for
the lies and we look at Time Magazine's
latest issue it's just a farrago of lies
it's all opinion pieces of journalism
when they look at the people who they
celebrate their get-togethers they're
not journalists I mean there's maybe six
journalists left in this country that
are actually doing investigative
research like Sara cada right like Molly
Hemingway when are they going to be
recognized by the Washington press corps
never never because they don't comport
with the narrative that we're Nazis and
the president is a dictator this is a
man whose grandchildren are Orthodox
Jews can you wrap your heads around it
New York Times CNN Huffington Post
BuzzFeed you're reprehensible for
calling this administration what you
call it I know the press he doesn't not
that he doesn't have a racist bone in
his body he doesn't have a racist
molecule in his body the stunning thing
I mean this is this is what why it was
such an honor to work for him the
stunning thing about Donald Trump is and
look I got a Bible in my pocket
I can swear on it I'll swear on this
Bible this man wants only two things for
all Americans he wants you and your
family to be safe and he wants you to
prosper
which is what all of prep America
American president should want but you
know what's stunning David he wants that
for you whether or not you voted for him
or not hmm
he doesn't care whether you voted for
Hillary he doesn't care whether you
wanted Bernie thorn
he doesn't care whether you stayed at
home and ate Doritos if you're an
American living here legally he wants
you to be safe from harm from gangs from
terrorism and he wants you to prosper
like he has prospered and the left this
is the answer to your question the left
will never ever believe that although it
is true and I test through it
so when they put you out there and as
you said you use or I got it all no no
no no that that that's what it's all
about right that's what it's all about
what you just said there when they put
you out there and as you said you
willfully went out to go for the for the
ban the Muslim ban I wouldn't we talked
about on the show moratorium but right
okay but I'm going to bed narrative okay
so we talked about in a bunch on the
show I did a bunch of videos I tried to
be very fair I have Muslim friends I've
had Muslims on the show and X Muslims
and I've had people that are critical
religion and people that are religious
on the whole freaking thing look most of
the countries the most of the most
populous countries of Muslim people were
not included on the band the original
list was applauded by the Obama
administration all that so I tried to
talk about it as fairly as possible but
it seems to be one of those issues and
then I think this will sort of lead us a
little bit into your book as well
talking about radical Islam and trying
to just you know make the distinction
between Islam as a set of ideas versus
Muslims as people and of course you
shouldn't be prejudiced and all of that
this seems to be basically the stickiest
thing that we have going right now right
like that like it's just quicksand to
even talk about it
you mean the threat of jihadism well
just kind of things that are there right
so well the quicksand of trying to make
the distinction of we have to be able to
talk about ideas and what we have to
fight for good ideas and against bad
ideas but at the same time make sure
that we're not being prejudiced towards
people and making sure that America
remains the open plurals pluralistic
society that it is look the argument in
and my book differing jihad is a very
simple one we live in the only country
ever created on the principle of
individual freedom and liberties and
granted to us not by the government but
by our Creator because we are made in
His image that the family father said
you are you have dignity because you are
made in the image of the creator not
because Washington says you have dignity
and that concept of the individual's
dignity and the freedom that it provides
is antithetical to the spectrum of
politics that says man is perfectible
and perfection can be created in real my
first degree was philosophy and theology
and I study at this event here in
California all politics can be can be
all ideological differences can be
summarized in just two camps it doesn't
matter which country you're in or what
era two camps those that believe truth
is objective and not man-made and those
who say no man can define truth and
perfection can be created here on earth
this statement that man defines truth
leads to the gas chambers and to the
gulags
okay now social justice warriors don't
realize that they're walking down the
same path but it's the same concept to
say I'm going to perfect the world and
there will be justice and equality no
you won't if we are free there will
never be justice for all and equality
for all as long as we are free because
evil is real evil exists man is fallen
and jihadism is just the latest version
like my book is a very simple argument
there's a connective tissue between our
Qaeda and Isis and the Nazis of the
Third Reich and the Communists of the
Soviet Union yes they worship different
things one worshipped an Aryan race one
we should work in class the other
worshipped their version of Islam but
guess what the connective tissue is
there all totalitarians and if you
disagree with them guess what yeah
you're going to be enslaved or murdered
end of story and if you if you deny that
reality and I I've trained no six seven
thousand federal officers I've trained
more than that in the military when
when a military professional an FBI
agent understands that his government is
telling him what he can or cannot say
about the threat group he's supposed to
be protecting us from then we have
problems when President Obama says in
2011 write a memo to the chair of the
Joint Chiefs and the then Attorney
General all characters and training of
FBI agents and the US military must not
mention Islam and especially must not
mention the word jihad mm-hmm well
that's like saying we're about to storm
the Normandy beaches and guys make sure
you're em ones loaded and your boots are
tied up but whatever you do don't
mention the word Nazi because you could
offend a German it's a bad SNL skit
David now it's insanity and the fact
that we weren't allowed to talk about it
truthfully that gets people killed
political correctness eventually can
lead to good people dying yeah so that
also explains why there's such craziness
in Europe right now right I mean we're
gonna see it seems to me that we're
gonna consistently see the rise of right
or far-right parties but it really is
just the symptom of not being able to
talk about these issues honestly let's
differentiate between the rise of two
different things
okay so we've just an election Hungary
we've seen the elections in Italy and
elsewhere we see in brexit let's not
conflate two issues there's the rise of
very disturbing groups like your beacon
Hungary there are really crypto
nationalists and and and feed off a long
seeded anti-semitic kind of irredentist
sentiment in the country so these are
the true sort of they're not all white
nationalist but the true sort of they
want ethno States and they want right
like well it's complicated because
there's history there there's Trianon
there's Versailles but they're bigots
ya know bigots okay then that you
mustn't conflate that with the Trump
phenomena and things like brexit its
original causation and I don't even use
the word populism I reject the word
populism unless your definition is part
of populism is those kinds of politics
that the elite disagrees with I'm pretty
sure that's that
standardization for me this isn't
populist the Trump winning or brexit
happening this is a reassertion of
democracy I mean why did Trump occur
because people on the left and the right
looked at DC and said you know I don't
know the difference between Sunni and
Shia but guess what
it's broken I don't know what a federal
budget should look like but we're
spending like drunken sailors so it's
the reassertion of accountable politics
Vice faceless bureaucracy or uni party
swamp runners whether they're in DC or
whether they're in Brussels so for me it
should be what we should welcome it with
open arms
this is a reassertion of accountable
government but for the left that wants
uniformity of thought and bigger
government
it's fascism so how does the hata then
does the right how do you police that I
know that you don't like that idea of
policing and government coming to fix it
but how do you make sure that the part
that you're worried about doesn't lead
the good part because I think from the
way at least from the way I see it the
left is always led now by its worst part
so then that's why they purge everybody
the video that you mentioned that I did
I'm praying are you that's what I talked
about I mean anyone that steps out of
group think you get purged and that's
why I think there's such a movement
towards libertarianism or classical
liberalism or whatever you wanna call it
so I see what the left's doing that how
do you make sure that doesn't happen on
the right where the far-right that
you're worried about yeah you think it's
a fair estimation to call it far right
and yeah yeah I don't even like the word
all right
yeah it's bogus I think those are just
that's a new label for nationalists or
or irredentist bigots yeah all right
that's a reader there rewrapping
themselves to be some fake to be fit for
polite you know company well I hate to
tell you exist I hate to tell you on
your Wikipedia page you cause you all
right of course I said right enough said
you know that the page that doesn't
allow the subject to correct yeah right
when I try and correct the lies it's
frozen interesting Wikipedia your I told
you right before we started but your
Wikipedia out of all of the ones that
because I usually just glanced they're
not out of fact but just to get a sense
of what's going on yours is such a mess
it's I've tried I've tried to correct
the friends who tried to correct it then
they froze it and then forget about it
yeah so what do you do
I'm sure that those two songs don't come
we a spine so those of us that have a
podium those that are out there those
that that wish to see the principles we
believe in in terms of the founding come
back and be celebrated in this country
we have to call them out like we don't
believe that you use legislation I mean
hate speech give me a break
I mean either you're inciting violence
or you're not either you're committing a
crime or you're not we don't need extra
labels and we don't extensive [ __ ] call
them out for what they are we need
people on the right to say you know what
he's a racist that all right think
that's just bigotry that's just a KKK
wrapped up in a new you know bow it's up
to us yeah do you think they're last I
think that's not gonna do it right
they're gonna use it they only use those
people to to silence the majority do you
think that we're not enough no not
enough by far we have begun but there's
a lot of work to do yeah does everything
that's happening in Europe right now and
there's definitely a distinction to be
made between what's happening in Eastern
Europe versus Western Europe and Eastern
Europe I think is dealing with some of
their existential crisis he's a little
bit better perhaps because Western
Europe still a little behind on the
political correctness stuff that you're
talking about does everything that's
happening in Europe right now does it
all come down to immigration do you
think no no no immigration was the blue
touch paper or on the firework no it's
it's the death of the representative
democracy I mean I watched this because
I grew up in the UK under Margaret
Thatcher for me Maggie the Gipper
Blessed Saint John Paul the second these
are my heroes and I remember writing to
school on the bus in the morning in West
London and the bus driver would be
Jamaican I did with my Indian or
Pakistani school buddy I read this
polish guy next to me I mean it's super
hurt Rajan as part of London and as far
as far as I was concerned these are all
Brits the guy must have might have had a
thickest Jamaican accent possible like
my friend Martin's mom cooked the best
Indian curries
but guess what we're all British yeah
that's gone you know what Tony Blair
came in when Clinton came in this idea
that you know the West is guilty and
words like British are pejorative you're
a good jarate you're Welsh or whatever
that was the death of these countries I
mean why do you think I'm in America I'm
a proud American citizen now because we
they lost the plot the things that the G
is that the fought for that that the
Tommies fought for makes safe spaces
really got nineteen-year-olds of being
blown up over Berlin in bomber planes
and you want a safe space this is in a
space of 70 years I mean what's going on
in London right now there's the land of
Churchill yeah it's shocking so I saw
I'm sure you saw this but just in the
last couple weeks they said London's
crime violent crime has now surpassed
New York City's for the first time in
history and then Sadiq Khan who's the
mayor of a statement saying you can't
carry knives I mean first off people are
walking out with Swiss Army knives a
woman that might want to protect herself
might want to have a knife in her pocket
I mean you know it seems like a mass
mental disorder to me but that's what
happens that is the natural progression
when you deny objective truth if
everything is plastic then you will get
wrapped around your own axle in
absurdities and for a mayor of one of
the most powerful cities in the world a
financial sense to say no one should
ever have a knife on them and nobody
needs a knife so every plumber every
tradesman every person working in a fish
market is suddenly out of a job
Sadiq Khan you're insane so what does
your Britain or Europe in a wider sense
have to do to reverse the tide on some
of this stuff I mean like Nigel Farage I
don't know I mean it's lucky this saying
it crops up in every nation every
country deserves the politicians they
elect don't [ __ ] alone get out there
well I see where I live outside DC I
mean you're the Conservatives who's so
fed up and they're constantly posting
stuff on Facebook what
you don't to do something about it have
you gone out with leaflets have you
given more than five dollars to your
local candidate have you given up and
surrendered I see this all the time that
people who say well greatest nation on
earth and then they say well you know
we're going purple and so many
bureaucrats moved in and what what are
you gonna do
what are you gonna do would you have
said that in 1776 but the founding
fathers have said what are you gonna do
no is this just a symptom of the success
of the West that we've just become so
successful that you're right we kind of
sit there and we sit on Twitter and we
complain all day but we're all talking
we're not doing anything like it's all
talk it's not due it's it's much more
than that it's deep I mean III went to
the Jesuits I studied philosophy under
them it was painful but I will I won't
regret a minute of it
identity is a function of history and
culture and values and if if you don't
study Western civilization in your
schools in your colleges this is what
happens if you don't understand why
people have dignity just that they do Oh
unless they're conservatives right this
is where you arrive at and and you know
who's responsible for this I don't blame
the left
David this is not the day this is not
the left capability it's ours it's the
conservatives the radicals when they saw
Paris in fire in 1968 believed that they
could do the same in America that we
could have a left-wing revolution this
is what your students for a Democratic
Society believed and when Bernardine
Dohrn and Bill Ayers took over the SDS
and tried to execute the Chicago days of
Rage what happened because Americans are
not rabble rousing leftists it died it
was a damp squib
optica they're Maoist revolution the
what was it the prairie fire manifesto
died instantly so what did they decide
they'd read that Trotsky they'd rather
let him even you a Hitler said give me
their children and I'll own their future
these people actually became tenured
professors in Chicago they became high
school teachers and what did we do on
the right we left them people who
avowedly believe America is evil were
allowed to influence our education
system to the point at which they pretty
much owned it but with exception of your
Hillsdale and Grove City they are in the
education system and and what was our
response homeschooling great I love the
movement but you're not gonna save my
daddy
that's not very enough yeah so it's
gonna be a hard slog it's gonna be 20 30
years of saying guys America means this
and it's nothing to do with your skin
color it's nothing to be a sexual
preference your social class your gender
America is eternal values and that's
that's gonna be a lot of work all right
so I want to shift a little bit to
foreign policy because I think that's
sort of one of your one of your would
you say that's one of your main
strengths love my my claim to fame is
kind of terrorism and stuff like this
but but I really deep Donna I'm a
strategy wonk yeah grand strategy is my
thing okay so we'll talk we'll talk in
the lens of strategy then so as we're
taping this right now I mentioned
earlier it's gonna it's gonna sit on the
shelf for a couple days so I don't want
to get too lost in anything that
happened today but at the moment it's a
little upside down in Syria you know
there might have been strikes already
from when we're taping this hungry just
had elections in your Wikipedia that I
referenced earlier it says you worked
for the for the guy who just won you
apparently you never worked for his
party I wasn't Victor lorta bonds
advisor yeah which is what it says I
mean at least what's your general
thoughts on foreign policy strategy like
what is a sensible policy and and is
Trump applying that view first things
first the great irony of our nation is
that we are the most powerful nation the
world has ever seen and until recently
we have been the dumbest and most a
strategic I mean we haven't done we
haven't thought or acted strategically
since about 1989 November the 9th with
war fell and and this is you know how
have we acted what would you say that
since then it's just oh well we were 90s
was just this kind of confused
what is National Security about the
lurching for the snooze button just who
are the threat is it China is a weapons
of mass destruction is that you can
Slavic it was just a mess and then we
had 2001 and 9/11 and we had just his
neocon disasters it's not an accident
these guys were former Trotskyites
because they're so naive the way they
look at the world that we're going to
create democracy at the end of a gun
barrel in a country with 36 languages
that defeated Alexander the Great and
the British Empire and the Soviets you
couldn't be stupider if you tried so you
know we've done some very very foolish
things because we haven't stuck to the
basics strategy at the end of the day is
about one thing it's about
prioritization based upon interests
right you've got to say some things are
more important than others and guess
what some countries are more important
than others and in a postmodern secular
world you're not allowed or no all
countries or Vanuatu is is important let
working it wrong it's not that I love
the people Vanuatu but no it's not a
geostrategic import to the country of
America so number one we have to
prioritize and I think this
administration I doff my cap to Nadia
shad lo a trauma masters deputy she held
the pen in the meetings that I was in on
the new national security strategy of
America and I'd tell you David it is the
first document of that name in 30 years
that deserves the name national security
strategy every administration has them
this is the first one that says this is
what we stand for these are our values
these are our friends these are our
enemies and this is what we're going to
prioritize prior to that it was laundry
lists of well we're gonna have to Front
Wars we're gonna save the whales and you
know no so you have to prioritize and
finally this administration is about
America first
we are not isolationist nor are we
interventionist this is really annoys me
that if you're a conservative for 20
years you were given two options button
a
invade other people's countries and
occupy them mm-hmm button be be you know
around Easter and close the you know the
curtains on the Pacific and the Atlantic
and say we don't care about anybody else
well guess what it's the most powerful
nation in the world there is a large
palette of options in the two it's got
to be something in the middle area it's
about being smart and it's about our
interests and it to summarize the
president's approach this isn't official
but I like it we have numerous former
generals an active generals from the
Marine Corps the highest level of the
administration of the Joint Chiefs chief
of staff secretary defense an
interesting thing is they all come from
the same Marine Corps division not just
a Marine Corps the same division and
that division has a motto no better
friend no worse enemy that's America
first so when you see someone like John
Bolton being now part of the cabinet and
if you were to look on you know not that
you can get truth out of Twitter but the
day it was happening you know everybody
saying this is gonna start World War
three and but you know just the general
hysterics and now John Bolton is
definitely suspect more of a neocon than
you're comfortable with is that I don't
think it's fair to call him a neocon I
don't think he's ideologically driven if
you watch the videos that he you know we
recorded of his speeches 20 years ago he
was sounding very much like Trump we're
American we have interest you want to
work with us fine if you don't there's a
problem so and I think it's very telling
that within 40 minutes of the
president's tweet about John coming on
board massive Bolton gave an interview
on Fox and they asked him about what are
you gonna be like as a national security
adviser and he gave a very interesting
answer he quoted Dean Acheson and you
know the the the doyen of foreign policy
in America and I don't if his true story
but John said Dean Acheson was once once
asked how do you have such a good
relationship with the president you
serve and Dean Acheson said well it's
very easy we may disagree on policy
issues but at the end of the day I never
forget who was elected president and it
wasn't me
that's a John borton 2.0 he understands
that unlike his previous
HR McMaster he's not there to lecture
the President or foist
his version of what you should do on to
the commander-in-chief he's there to be
an honest broker and provide a pallet of
options because guess who gets to decide
the person who was elected president so
I am very excited about John I'm I'm as
excited about Mike Pompeo coming from
the CIA to the State Department that we
are in very good hands David so how do
you make sure if it's between the pure
isolationists and yeah and the neo-cons
or something something like the nation
builders something like that how do you
make sure that not everything that you
do outside of our borders becomes
something much bigger I mean look we're
still at war in Afghanistan I don't
think anyone knows why I mean can you
can you tell me why we're at war in
Afghanistan can anyone tell you why why
we went why we went to Afghanistan in
October one is the only reason we should
be there today nothing's changed okay
the idea that girls go to school I love
it I get it and that people can listen
to music freely and the Taliban won't
execute you my parents lived under
communism my father suffered under
fascism he protected his fellow Jewish
classmates during the occupation of
Budapest I get it I don't like those
kinds of systems but there's only one
reason we were there to make sure that
that piece of land mass would never ever
again be used to execute mass casualty
attacks in Manhattan in Washington or in
a field in Pennsylvania
end of story it's not about building a
Ring Road around Kabul they're not even
the Soviets could finish mm-hmm it's not
about building hospitals I'm sorry you
never make the ideal the enemy of the
good what the president does is he looks
at things as questions of possibility
you cannot be a massively successful
realtor in the toughest market in new in
the world which is New York real estate
if you have a filter that distorts
reality I mean either this square
footage is worth X or it's not worth X
according to the market and that's how
he approaches these issues so
Afghanistan's only important to make
sure bad guys don't use it again to kill
Americans in America so yeah so you
would say or at least if you were if you
had to guesstimate basically what he
believes you would say that he believes
that still
keeping us there at the moment is still
accomplishing yeah oh I don't have to
guesstimate only that yeah so you
believe that well because it just seems
unclear that he will he will never I
tell you right this 71 year old man who
is now the most powerful man in the
world will never ever ever buy into a
nation-building scenario anywhere
outside of the United States not
happening for the next seven years
end of story and the idea that you have
my followers on Twitter tearing their
hair out that Bolton's going to have us
invade Syria guys get a grip on reality
and you know stop talking about crisis
actors and tinfoil hat garbage it's not
gonna happen while the president's the
president well that I tweeted something
to that effect the day of the Bolton
thing because it also reminds me that
people don't understand basic deterrence
you have to bring in people that you
know talk a big game so that / not to
raise hell oh yeah right the man who was
going to take us to war what did he do I
think the success in North Korea today
has in a large part being part had been
thanks to his tweets because that's how
you deal with dictators you make fun of
them they hate that
and then you ridicule them right and
then you do what you scared them oh and
lo and behold they want to negotiate for
the first time in 65 years well isn't
that interesting do you think there's
any chance he would ever give up his
nukes about 3% because at that point
what leverage does he ever left right so
that well you still think it's worth
having the talks to figure out what we
can absolutely because what's happened
for the last 25 years
escalation escalation escalation II we
we have given into nuclear blackmail
since Bill Clinton so yeah we have to at
the end of the day we have to remember
1953 was not a peace treaty 1953 in
Korea was a ceasefire in an armistice
mhm that is actually a war that's just
simply been frozen for 65 years would be
nice to have a little bit of a peace
treaty or something yeah how much of
what's happening in the world right now
do you you must be thrilled I assume
with everything going on at the UN that
Haley has basically walked in there and
John Bolten 2.0 yeah yeah I mean she
strikes me as I almost wonder did Trump
really know what he was getting with hi
olli yeah did anyone think anybody did
yeah we're did you know her at all where
do you think that that come on I don't
know as a friend she found herself she
found herself and more power to it what
what usefulness do you see in the UN at
this point because it seems like truly
it seems like the most corrupt should be
backward pushed into the river I mean
really I mean that well the building's
basically other now they're gonna quote
that and go you see he was calling for
her I'm right I think to be knocked into
the room look the idea was a good idea
in 1945 in San Francisco that let's have
an organization that stops us from
killing 60 million people again but when
you lock in dictatorships like China and
Russia into the Security Council with
veto power and then you create this this
Empire of UN organizations I mean it has
there been a year in the last 20 years
that we haven't seen a UN scandal
whether it's money for oil whether it's
UN troops raping children in Africa have
we seen it one year without UN scandal I
don't think so so try and reform and if
you can't question the validity of what
it does so forget I'm not talking about
you know the children's rights
organizations and food food security I'm
talking about its main mission which is
stability and safety it's failed
abysmally yeah what do you make of the
endless obsession with Israel that
something like 47 of the last 51
resolutions are against Israel usually
voted on by countries I'm sorry but that
alone is a reason to dissolve the UN I
mean what a lack of moral compass
what an utter bankruptcy of the morality
that there are nations in the world that
actually still have slavery going on
slavery where we're basic human rights
for individuals are not guaranteed based
upon sex based upon
lifestyle choices and you're going to
lambast Israel the only real democracy
in the Middle East yeah i think i think
you know i mean that in and of itself is
reason enough to question the nature of
the UN so is the US sort of in an odd
position where it's like if we don't do
anything nothing can get done sort of
and that that then puts us endlessly in
these Quagmire's or at least in these
positions where we can either watch the
world burn or get involved in things
where we may end up adding to the
burning in the first place like for
example you know with Russia going into
Crimea you know they gave up their
weapons right they gave up the weapons
they said all right NATO is gonna take
care of us but what that really means is
the United States is gonna take care of
you and I'm not saying we should have
gone in and done anything there but that
we're in this endless situation now
where it is either us there there is no
international fighting but but again
very super careful not to get caught in
a binary dichotomy you can absolutely
say a world without American leadership
is a more dangerous world because it was
for the last eight years look I mean we
had a government that actually said
we're going to lead from behind which is
an oxymoron you cannot lead from behind
we're going to have strategic patience
which means we do nothing and allow
others to act what happened you name it
from China building fake military bases
on fake islands to Isis to Russia
invading it was just a disaster
Egypt we back the guy the other guys
then we back the other so yeah to say
that a world learn American leadership
is is more dangerous is true but that
doesn't mean that we have to fix
everybody's problem and that's that's
where smart strategy comes in where you
say but we have a moral duty to espouse
certain values but that doesn't mean we
are responsible for all human beings
because because the American Revolution
says the opposite each nation is
responsible the citizens are responsible
if you don't like your system do
something about it because guess what we
did against the most powerful empire in
the world so again it's about
happy medium in the middle and being
smart about it and again without being
callous being realistic right there are
trosset e's everywhere from Rwanda to
Yugoslavia bara American taxpayers gonna
pay for fixing all of them are we
responsible are they responsible for
what's happening in their country sure
are the timezone we could perhaps help
them uh-huh but it's a balance right to
balance all right so let's shift back to
your book yeah so defeating jihad it
seems to me that the the main sort of
narrative on this is not that we can
defeat it but we should live with it
that there's a degree of it with which
we should just live which is don't carry
knives in London and it's you know we're
gonna put up more barricades so the
trucks can't be driven into buildings or
into shopping centers or just down the
street and killing people that we can't
really defeat this ideology we just have
to manage it yeah I suspect you do not
agree with that premise no because we've
defeated ideologies before you can't
look Vera idiot to run around with you
know swastika armbands today I get it so
Nazism hasn't disappeared but we have
made it so enough Emma that if you walk
down the street with a Nazi flag you
will be rejected by society instantly
the same thing with the KKK right sadly
not with Che Guevara for the hammer and
sickle right right right but but there
are ways to defeat ideologies or to put
them in a box where they're laughable
and and everybody shuns them we have to
do the same thing with jihadism this is
my argument this is the conclusion of
the book we have to be as effective in
dealing in amaizing the message of gia
because very simply put killing jihadis
is great but at the end of the day
body-bags is a metric not a good metric
it didn't work in Vietnam doesn't work
today because guess what if you've got a
recruiting pool that's massive that is
recruit new Gianni's so what's your
victory condition your victory condition
is when the life style of jihad is no
longer sexy from Brussels to San
Bernardino how do you do that you make a
laughingstock you discredit that value
system
we're not asked I mean white skin
Catholic isn't gonna do it right but we
help president Sisi we help King
Abdullah of Jordan will help MBS in
Saudi Arabia
I mean MBS the historic things he said I
mean nothing about Israel in just the
last few weeks
yeah that's how we win because sooner or
later enough people say you know those
guys are losers that's how we win but
but you only do that if you get to talk
about it truthfully you've got to be
able to talk about the Koran what jihad
means the history of the religion
because if you can't talk about it
honestly you never going to treat it
accurately yeah we're not very good at
that though well very political
correctness right I mean imagine if you
know you're a doctor and you've got a
patient that comes in with your third
stage you know lymphoma but your
hospital administrator because it's a
scary word is bad the use of the word
cancer you can't say it right it's just
not allowed yeah and then you have the
other patient what well you know you're
dehydrated go home drink some water and
take some aspirin
what happens your patient I it's the
same thing if you can't diagnose a
geostrategic issue accurately however
much money you throw it it you will not
solve the problem so are you concerned
at all that just even if it's purely
because of the way the media frames
things that perhaps Trump is not the
right person to lead the fight against
this that for whatever whatever he's
gonna say about jihad or radical Islamic
terrorism or the rest now even if he
said everything the exact way that you
wanted it he said cleanly and clearly
and correctly defined all of that that
he may not be the right messenger on
this just because of the filter it has
to get through to get to reality he's
not the right messenger domestically
because of what political correctness
has wrought in our country but he is
absolutely the right messenger
internationally watch the video of his
Riyadh speech don't watch him watch the
fifty-three Muslim Arab heads of state
and their body language because man did
he guys you got a problem in your mosque
in your society is extreme is that you
have to deal with it it was tough and
you think there'd be or negative and
arms crossed
they were beaming right
see see Abdullah we're going over
finally a fun guy who understands our
problem and what is giving us tough love
so yeah he is absolutely the right guy
to fix this internationally which is
where it needs to be fixed
domestically now the political
correctness things better getting away
yeah the media insanity so do you think
he has more support from foreign heads
of state and then we'll have her have a
sense I mean even up the g8 there was a
feeling of like that actually these guys
kind of liked him oh I can tell you yeah
I told people before the inauguration
you have no idea even if you voted for
him
you have no idea how successful he will
be internationally cuz he's a straight
shooter and because he's an alpha dog
and guess what in a lot of places
outside of Berkeley they like of that
right because they know what you're
talking about
they don't have to walk on eggshells
they understand your direction so yeah
internationally our prestige as a nation
has skyrocketed in you know outside of
the European Union and maybe you know
certain Centurion countries exempted
right yeah absolutely
so I know we can do a whole other show
on this but but very quickly just on
Russia and collusion as someone that has
been around the administration you've
mentioned some of these people already
Flynn you know down the road what can
you tell me about that and is there
anything that people should be worried
about or do you think this is all gonna
actually point just back to the
Democrats which every time I see every
time it seems to point to Trump yeah go
a little bit further than he going oh
well wait a minute that was actually the
Democrats my good friend has the best
morning show in DC Chris plumb the radio
host it's actually nationally syndicated
now and I have to credit him with this
he says it's that it's the last scene
from The Hunt for Red October when the
fad captain tupolev launches the the
torpedoes against you know Sean Connery
on the radio October and it takes the
fuses off and then what happens remember
his XO says you idiot you've killed us
the thing comes back and sinks them yes
it this is the
the most hilarious boomerang in history
right I'll tell you what the president
told me in the Oval Office just the two
of us it was very frustrating too one
day I think maybe Jared had just
testified to giving his speech his
little press conference and he said they
will not find anything because there is
nothing and you know what I take that to
the bank there is no rush of collusion
how could there be after the last 15
months from arming the Ukrainians to the
XL pipeline to Anwar to finally after 30
years the first president to ever get
NATO to finally stump up the 2% of GDP
that they promised they'd spend on
defense to our own military expenditure
increases every significant policy
decision as president has taken with
regards to Russia has been bad for that
former KGB colonel so the idea that
we're colluding you have to be on drugs
or be so ideologically blind to believe
that well then what do we do with this
this layer you know whatever that you
you reference deep state before whatever
yeah what do we do with this thing you
know even ongoing the the investigation
to me the Mueller investigation which
seems odd to me is that I don't know
what the actual I don't know that they
ever laid out what their mission is
other than to find writing oh it's a
crime right and that who's right it's a
collusion to commit concerta can
collusion to conspire in a crime okay
but what's the crime because if it's
Russia misrepresenting itself or
perverting the truth on Facebook well
then Zuckerberg should be right charged
then then you know Anderson Cooper
should be in the dock what are the
charges that have been brought
outrageously ridiculous or lying to
federal investigators you you would
probably be able to be caught in a
perjury trap today okay because not
everybody remembers what they did and
how they did it
perjury traps about what you said to
somebody irrespective of Russia
that's not Donald Trump's problem why a
fraud
eight years ago when manna fort worked
the Ukrainian president what's that got
to do with Russian collusion nothing my
worry is that Muller is not a good actor
if you look at who he's hired it's clear
that there's massive buyers and this
report he's writing for Congress is
simply going to be a political weapon in
the elections and and that's not how
justice is served that's not a rule of
law that's a law enforcement official
getting involved in politics so that's
what I'm concerned about also whether
whether you think something for the
people that are watching us that think
something happened or didn't happen what
I'm more concerned about is that we're
entering this new phase where whether
it's Trump that's president or it's a
Democrat that it's president or it's a
different Republican or whatever that
we're just gonna endlessly also have
this layer that all it does is
investigate itself waste money but you
know just constantly just be keeping us
all in this state where we never know
what's real because if you listen to
half of the pundits on television I mean
their implication is that Russia has
installed our president in which case
that's probably the bit single biggest
active war in the history of the world
and what are you actually saying do we
take Trump out and then do you take out
pence and now should Paul Ryan if you
take it to its logical conclusion oh do
we have Paul Ryan is what are you all
resident then and right where are you
really taking this and that's what I'm
worried about is that we're just gonna
end up in this constant state where yes
we'll have a Democrat and then a
Republican in order but we'll really be
caught in just kind of all government
can do is investigate itself yeah we
more than anything else I see myself as
an optimist but you're giving me a real
challenge what I see myself as an
optimist too I think I'm I'm a realist
so for months and months and months I
refuse to use the phrase deep state I
really thought that was a you know
tinfoil hat he kind of thing yeah before
the record I don't even know that I've
even said it once on this show it sort
of pops up an answer okay I use it now
because I've seen it I've seen it inside
the administration when you go to enough
national security council meetings that
are classified that is the the the
pinnacle of policymaking in America
outside of the Oval Office and this is
where policy is made everybody's in the
room from the air
see then you've got the outstations on
secure BTC from DIA tether Joint Chiefs
CIA state you name it right he sit there
as a newly appointed political and you
listen for two hours on a big issue isis
russia whatever it is and not one
participant mentions the name of the
president or what he said yesterday in
warsaw or what his objective is given
that specific issue and you see this
happen again and again and again and
you're the guy at the end of the
conversation with a funny accent says
excuse me ladies and gentlemen you do
know what the president said about x
yesterday can we actually do that the
deep state is real when you've got GS
15s and SES is saying well I've been
here for 20 years I know this guy's
gonna be here for four I know better
that's bad for democracy so it'll be
clear that you don't think it's some
sort of massive underground conspiracy
you think it's just the apparatus it's
just the old Washington apparatus so
that I don't think these people who
think Obama's sitting in a cave
somewhere with a joystick he's lazy
you'd never be a mastermind he's not
Specter rights not Blofeld but but no
there's a culture in government that's
antithetical to an undermining that
undermining the president on a daily
basis but but there there is concerted
effort in the media oh my god
I mean Ben Rhodes brags about AI that
game I can't believe well he says my
buddies the left-wing journalists are
morons and then my echo chamber he built
this machine that was was this
incestuous connection between people in
the West Wing people in a think-tank
community and their buddies in the media
I mean look at the attack pieces on
anybody me or whatever it's very
interesting somebody do a case study
adrenaline score one attack piece will
drop at 7:00 a.m.
by two o'clock in the afternoon 30 he'll
get written will just simply cut and
paste but if you don't know that it
looks as though my gosh coke is a
fascist
look it's one guy's article that was
written because Ben Rhodes told them to
ride it that comes and multiplies on the
right how do we react well I got my
op-ed into
- we'll review this one right there's a
golf in terms of managing narrative the
left built built a whole ecosystem and
we're still in the 1980s you know or
we'll take out a full-page ad in The
Washington Times well that's why I
wouldn't discuss right yeah I think it's
so important to not on I think most
people especially just because of the
way social media works they immediately
go to the full-on conspiracy of Obama
with the joystick or just some other
vert you know the globalist thing and
this whole where to me it's like they're
there what you just described seems more
realistic to me that there's an
apparatus there that then is still
connected to the idea that seems we can
we can discuss that in a sensible way
with one addition and and I appreciate
this not having been you know in the
target has or the crosshairs for so long
they have an advantage because our side
is predicated on what David the
individual right manifest destiny is are
ugly individualism we believe in the
individual the left by definition is a
collective entity I mean there are
elements of the Borg in the left and it
is a it truly is a collective collective
mob mentality a friend of mine on Murray
if you're watching I mean thank you
there is a smile when when one guy goes
after Gawker or Bannen or whoever the
president there's this massive
collective pile on it's not a conspiracy
yeah but it but it's a collect they're
all on the same hymn sheet they don't
need direction
well they say oh yeah let's go after him
which is which puts us on the right at a
disadvantage
yeah so this is just sort of an emerging
group thing it's because of the actual
thing yeah Wow we could do we're gonna
do this again
uh-oh so this is so much fun yeah this
was an absolute pleasure for more on dr.
Gorka cuz I feel like I have to say last
I know well I would have I'm a pro when
I'm doing that later okay Sebastian but
I feel like dr. Gorka I mean you should
be a Star Wars character it's all over
there for more on sebastian follow him
on twitter it's at zeb Gorka
[Music]
you